(audience applauding)
- Welcome to New York.
- [Kelly] Thank you.
- It was such a blast when I
heard you were coming here.
I said, "Maybe we can be on the show-"
- [Kelly] I know.
and I don't have to go out to LA.
It's awesome.
- I know. I love it. I
love coming here too.
We came here last season.
It opened up premiere week,
and we loved it so much,
we did it again.
- And the city is really
back in a big way now.
- [Kelly] I know.
You're a music fan, we know this
'cause you've played music
- I am.
with us before.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] So do you get out?
Do you do shows and all that?
- You know, my band,
we try to get together.
And you know, Covid's been very difficult.
We're gonna, I think,
rehearse in another
week for the first time
in over a year.
- Oh, wow!
- [Lester] But I love
live music.
- Mm-hm.
- I mean, that's part of one
of the gems of New York City,
is going to hear live music.
- Yeah, and you can hear it everywhere.
Literally, I've spent the whole month here
and I've been in Central Park,
and everywhere you go there's
a different style of music,
different musicians playing.
It's so cool. Yeah.
- I love street musicians
on the subway, you know.
- [Kelly] I know.
- Sometimes you'll be in the subways
and guys will break out an acapella.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, Doo-wop stuff.
- And it's just so cool.
- Well, I heard that NBC,
actually, I love this.
They rejected you the first time
(laughing)
that you wanted to be a
part of the news, right?
- They did. I just happened,
'cause we talked about this.
I just happened to have a copy.
- [Kelly] I love this.
(audience laughter)
- A copy-
- And you, you,
- [Lester] of the letter.
- you have like 5 billion shows now.
- Okay. This is uh, this is dated.
See, you have the old NBC logo on it.
But anyway, it was from August 11th, 1977.
I was three months out of high school,
and I sent my, I wanted to be on radio,
I sent my tape and a resume.
Anyway, I get this, "Mr. Lester Holt."
"Dear Mr. Holt. Thank you
for your interest in WNBC.
I was impressed with your credentials.
However, it's not exactly
what we're looking for at this time.
Good luck with your career."
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
- Good luck?
- Thank you for that good luck,
'cause it really, really worked.
- Oh yeah. I really,
that's amazing though.
And I, I love that you share this story
'cause a lot of people get deterred.
Like, a lot of people think American Idol
was my first thing I ever auditioned for.
And I've been turned away from,
there was like a thing called Popstars
that got turned away down, down from.
Many things that you get turned down from
and you have to keep going.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I just think
it's such a great story
for people to hear
from people like you that
have had so much success.
It wasn't overnight, like it-
- [Lester] Yeah.
- You have to keep, there's many doors
slammed in our faces.
- [Lester] It rarely happens.
It rarely happens overnight.
You just have to have that resilience.
That sense of, you know,
figure out, you know, why.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You know, why it was a no and how to
turn it into a yes next time.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I love that.
(audience applauding)
Well, you just earned a couple big honors.
So, tell everybody about that.
That's so cool. It's so cool.
- Yeah, we won the NBC Overall Excellence,
the Edward R. Murrow Award.
And also for NBC Nightly News,
which we're incredibly proud of.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Lester] You know, we work
really, really hard on
that broadcast every night.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Lester] It's, you know,
we have to bring it and it's
just nice to be recognized,
you know, by your peers,
on that level.
- [Kelly] Yeah.